Komm mit in die wilde Willwille, in die wilde Willwille, in die wilde Willwille, der Welt vom Podcast-Uvo, komm mit mit Florentin Will, will mit Florentin Will und Stefan Kizetitz, Kizetitz, Kizetitz.
So.
So, jetzt sag ich es.
Das war das letzte Hörer-Intro.
Ich sage es hier Verweise.
Jetzt reicht es.
Jetzt gibt es hier Ärger. So geht es nicht.
Übrigens eine Melodie von Jack Offenbach.
Ne, von Mike tatsächlich. Ja, ja. Mike, vielen Dank für dieses Hörer-Intro. Danke, Mikey. Danke schön für dieses fantastische Intro und dass du uns weiter beweist, dass es kein Fehler war, unsere Intros seit 200 Folgen von willkürlichen Amateurmusikern bereitgestellt zu haben. Danke dir. Danke dir. Super. Und bevor wir unseren Namen nennen, noch kurz. Ihr wartet ja alle schon auf Kohlen. Wie heißen die Stimmen? Ich kann sie auseinanderhalten. Wie viele Stimmen sind es? Ich weiß nicht, sind es vier, sind es fünf? Keine Ahnung. Kurz nochmal, diese Melodie wurde komponiert von Jack Offenbach. Die Mike heißt die. Ja, aber das ist doch, das basiert ja auf ... Da ist auch die Melodie der Tex Avery. Ich dir die Mail zeigen. Tex Avery ist Florentin fuckingville. So. Und Stefan fucking Tietze! Und das ist ein Kölner. Jack Offenbach war ein Kölner. Nein, Kölner Jung. Ein Kölner Jung, wie man sagt. Der hat damals die Tex Avery Show. Nein, der war klassischer Musiker, hat lustige Songs gemacht, das war einer davon. Und irgendwann war es Tax-Every-Show-Intro. Und jetzt ist es das Intro von Folge 256 des Podcasts. Frage, hat sich Mikey Mike Mike Gedanken gemacht zum Urheberrecht? Nein, ich glaube, Mike hat einfach am Piano ein bisschen improvisiert und dem ist gar nicht klar, dass sich hier Jack Offenbach plagiiert hat, sondern oft macht man hier Sachen und weiss gar nicht,
dass es Plagiat ist. Ich meine,
klar, du kannst ja auch sagen, egal welche Melodie,
die man findet,
wurde wahrscheinlich schon irgendwo gemacht. Genau, es gibt nur acht Töne,
so viele Möglichkeiten ganz ähnlich geben.
Ihr hört das Podcast-Ufo.
Einen von ein paar Podcasts da draußen
habt ihr euch entschieden für das Podcast-Ufo.
Danke erstmal. Erstmal, und das muss man wirklich sagen, danke. Die Chance, dass ihr hier gelandet seid, ist denkbar gering. Ja, danke, dass ihr euch für, ihr steht vor dem wunderbaren bunten Baum der Podcast-Landschaft und ihr habt euch für uns entschieden, vielleicht nur nebenbei, vielleicht nur ganz leise im Auto, vielleicht aus Versehen, vielleicht einer der vielen, die wahrscheinlich einfach an Ufos interessiert sind und immer noch warten, jetzt kommt doch mal endlich zu dem Ufo. Wo sind die Aliens, wo sind die Aliens, Roosevelt, wo sind die, seien die Aliens? Roosevelt, Area 51, wo sind die Themen? Wo sind sie, wo sind sie, aber sehr, sehr geduldig, extrem geduldig. Ich habe die Riesenangst, dass Leute den Podcast neu entdecken. Ja, ich auch. Lass mich elaborieren. Ich habe Angst, dass Leute bei dieser Folge einsteigen.
Und diese Angst habe ich seit 150 Folgen, circa. Weil ihr kommt nicht mehr mit, ihr kommt nicht unmöglich, könnt ihr verstehen. Naja, Früte Grebig ist ein guter Film, ist glaube ich jetzt nicht was, was man das siebte Mal gehört hat. Wir pfeifen gern Jurassic Park, Früte Grebig ist ein guter Film und Harry Potter haben wir keine Ahnung vonhm, ganz kurz, wir können direkt mal einsteigen in eine unserer unbeliebtesten Rubriken, die Podcast-Ufo-Korrektur. Wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, und zwar zum Thema Reinkarnation. Also die Idee der Reinkarnation, dass irgendein Diktator wieder reinkarniert wird, irgendwo anders, in einem Jungen, und dann muss dieser Junge gefunden werden. In Paule. In Paule. Nenn ihnenn ihn beim Namen. Ja, und wird dann von dem System, muss dann den Geist des Diktators sozusagen suchen. Und ja, ich sag mal so, die Idee gibt's schon. Ich bin es gewohnt, dass meine Kunst auch Rückgriffe nimmt auf die echte Welt und satirisch, karikierend echte Dinge aufgreift. Das ist jetzt gerade Hochdeutsch für einen Zeitreisender, hat den Podcast gehört und hat den Film in 2008 gemacht. Ja, und zwar, was ganz interessant ist, die Idee nach der Reinkarnation zu suchen, ist natürlich ein akutes Problem im Buddhismus, völlig richtig, und ich habe mich mal eingelesen, aka zwei Sätze auf Wikipedia gelesen, zum Thema Punch in Lama. Aka nicht nur, nicht in Wikipedia angeklickt, sondern in der Beschreibung, die man schon sah, bei Google gelesen. Alles, was zu Gelb unterlegt ist. Zum Thema Punch in Lama. Es gibt nämlich nicht nur den Dalai Lama, sondern es gibt auch den Punch in Lama. Und es gibt Slide Lama.. Und die Sliding-Lama?
Nee, Slider-Lama ist das Spiel auf ICQ.
Kennst du das noch? Ach so, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Slider-Lama, das kennst du noch?
Nein.
Das ist das lustigste Spiel der Welt.
Das ist das coolste Lama, ist Slider-Lama.
Du musst ein Lama über ein Eis, eisflächlich sliden oder was?
Nein, Slider-Lama ist, du musst, glaube ich, das ist so wie Candy Crush, du musst halt
so fünf Symbole einer Reihe haben. Du kennst Slst leider Lama. Aber was hat das mit Lama zu tun? Lamas. Es sind Lamas. Die Süßigkeiten sind Lamas. Nein, du hast Teams unten, die wechseln die Seite. Jetzt röckel die Logik von deinem Spiel aber ganz schnell zusammen. Nein, du kennst das Spiel Schweiss. Du hast doch auch Isaac Humor gehabt. Nee, tatsächlich nicht. Nein? Nee, tatsächlich gar nicht. Du hast unten zwei Teams aus Lamas. Ich hab mich aufgerichtet. Ich bin noch nie so ... Sein Zeigefinger erigiert in meine Richtung. Ich war noch nie so wach bei einem Podcast-Ufrau aufzeichnet. Also, du hast unten zwei Teams. Und je nachdem, wie gut es für dich läuft, desto mehr Lamas kommen auf deine Seite. Es passiert so halt da, wo Lamas sind, so peruanische Kultur. Azteken, da so grob, die Ecke. Das ist so die ... da verordnet sich das Spiel. Aber es ist alles so sehr schlechte Grafik. Okay, unabhängig davon. Zurück zu deinen Lamas. Es gibt Dalai-Lama und Panchen-Lama. Und die Idee ist so ein bisschen ... Das wusste ich nämlich gar gar nicht, Dalai Lama ist ja das Oberhaupt der buddhistischen Glaubensgemeinschaft und der scheint immer wieder zu reinkarnieren. Also das ist derselbe wie letztes Jahr, aber halt wieder reinkarniert. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Der ist derselbe wie im letzten Jahr, aber der lebt doch noch, derjenige vom letzten Jahr. Nee, wenn der Dalai Lama stirbt, dann geht der in einen anderen rein. Und dann ist der der neue Dalai Lama. Ach so, aber nur ganz kurz, wait. Ich glaube, alle Fragen, die du hast, ergeben sich durch diese Doppelspitze. Punchin-Lama, Dalai Lama.. Punchin-Lama? Es gibt Punchin-Lama, Fightin-Lama, Jumpin-Lama. Jumpin-Slide-Lama. Oh, diese Geschichte wird noch eine sehr dramatische Wendung nehmen. Da wirst du deine Witze bereuen. Sind wir zu lustig gerade? Nee, ist okay. Du stellst völlig zu Recht die Frage, wie soll das gehen? Weil wenn der Dalai-Lama stirbt, dann ist jetzt der neue Dalai-Lama in irgendeinem Hund
und niemand weiss, ja, woher soll ich das
wissen? Dafür gibt es wiederum den
Panchen-Lama, der
die Reinkarnation vom Dalai-Lama
boxt, sucht
und
gegen den er kämpfen muss und wenn er
gewinnt, ist er der neue Dalai-Lama.
So, und jetzt fragst du dir,
aber was passiert, wenn der...
Jetzt ist mir alles so verworren.
Diese Witze greifen in die Realität an, und in meinem Kopf entsteht ein Krieg. Nein, der Panchen-Lama sucht die Reinkarnation des Dalai Lamas. Genau. Was heißt ... Ich hab mir viele pragmatische Fragen geträgt. Ich bin's, sagt er. Weil, wie sieht dieses Suchen aus Also stell dir mal ganz konkret vor, du bist Punch in Lama und du sitzt in deinem Büro und der Dalai Lama ist seit zwei Wochen tot und alle sagen, und dein Chef, Entschuldigung, Herr Lama, haben Sie schon Dalai Lama gefunden? Ach, war das, soll ich das jetzt, war das schon, war das so akut? Wir hatten gesagt, es ist wieder vor Lager auf Mittwoch. War das so akut? Natürlich ist das akut, die Glaubensgemeinschaft wartet. Herr Lama, ich will bis heute Abend Ergebnisse sehen. Und dann scrollst du durch Facebook und denkst dir, könnte der sein. Wir gucken uns so um, wir mit unserem Podcast-Ufo und nehmen so auf und dann merken wir, dass plötzlich vor unserem Studio auf der anderen Strassenseite immer so ein Mönch steht mit so diesem gelben Oranger Van mit verflächteren Ein fliegender Van So ein Abhörvan ganz in Orange. Und da sind so glatzköpfige Mönche drin mit ihren, muss man sagen, sehr schicken Roben. Gute Wahl, Orange, gute Wahl. Also Kleidung, man kann die gut sehen.
Top-5-Weltreligion-Kleidung, wirklich.
Und die stehen ja die ganze Zeit und beobachten uns, weil die die Vermutung haben, dass du der Dalai Lama bist.
Das kann schon sein.
Kann das jeder sein oder muss man dafür Buddhist sein? Also, ich sag mal so, bis jetzt waren es keine Frauen, sondern immer nur in der Regel Kinder, die dann irgendwie genommen werden als neuer Dalai Lama und halt irgendwie sowas aus der Umgebung. Also es ist jetzt selten passiert, dass es irgendwie ein Nürnberger geworden ist, wo man dann sagt so, oh jetzt zufälligerweise. Oder ein Igel. Das ist ja auch so die Sache. Ich glaube, die Reinkarnation ist halt schon ein bisschen gehfaul, weil der Dalai Lama stirbt und dann sagt er, jetzt gehe ich halt fünf Kilometer nach Osten. Der sagt nicht, ich bin jetzt in Karibik, irgendein Surfer-Dude ist jetzt der neue Dalai-Lama, wird nicht passieren. Den kriegst du auch erstmal aus seinem Strandparadies heraus. Nee, kriegst du nicht raus. Du kriegst den Surfer aus dem Strandparadies, aber du kriegst den Dalai-Lama ein. Was ein Riesenproblem war, tatsächlich 1609 war mal ein Surfer--Dude aus Kalifornien, der neue Dalai Lama, und das war ein Riesenproblem. Er wollte auch nicht. Der wollte nicht, und du hast es nicht besucht. Aber ein geiler Film, ein geiler Film. Ja, deswegen sage ich doch, da sind noch so viele Geschichten unerzählt, irgendwie irgendein Typ, der da gar nicht reinpasst, so ein Fish-out-of-the-sand-Ding, das ist ein Surfer, muss dann da nach Tibet. Jeff Bridges ist der neue Dalai Lama. So, und jetzt ist so die Sache, der Panchen-Lama sucht den Dalai Lama, aber wenn jetzt der Panchen-Lama stirbt, wer sucht jetzt den neuen? Der Dalai Lama. Genau, dann sucht wiederum der Dalai Lama den neuen Panchen-Lama. Wird er dann zum Panchen-Lama? Nein, der bleibt Dalai Lama. Bleibt Dalai. Das heißt, ein gutes System, weil die suchen sich immer gegenseitig. Und das abschließend zu bewerten, wie du, der schon den Rotschild rausgeholt hat, einen dicken Strich unter die ganze Geschichte gemacht hat und jetzt schon eine Zensur aufschreit, habe ich noch sehr viele Fragen. Aber du hast diese Doppelspitze und die spielen sich halt über die Jahrhunderte den Ball hin und her. Du hast diese männliche, alte, glatzköpfige Männerriege, Doppelspitze, die sich die ganze Zeit die Bälle hinterher spielen. Was ist denn, wenn der Panchen-Lama so ein bisschen machtgeil wird und sagt, ich bin der neue Dada-Lama? Nee, das geht nicht. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Du kannst dich gleichzeitig Panchen und Dada-Lama nehmen. Ich bin's, ich bin's. Weil Panchen-Lama und Dada-Lama sind Sonne und Mond von Tibet, vom Buddhismus. Das heißt, die sind beide wichtig, obwohl wir alle wissen. Aber Dalai Lama ist schon Sonne. Ja, aber das ist ja auch wichtig. Also was würden wir ohne den Mond sagen? Ich als Dalai Lama bin schon Sonne. Wenn ich den Mond, ich lasse sie köpfen, wenn sie sage, ich bin Mond. Wirklich, das ist ganz ungewöhnlich, buddhistisch. Ja, weiss ich nicht. Ich weiss es auch nicht. Ich bin Informatiker aus Brüssel. Ich habe keine Ahnung von eurer Religion. Wir wissen alles über Afrika, wir wissen nichts über Buddhismus. Gut, schön. Antenne Armen, die verschiedenen Weltreligionen in der Welt. Antenne Armen? Die verschiedenen Weltreligionen, kurz und knackig in 30 Sekunden. Es sind nicht so viele. Es sind nicht so viele. Wie können wir aufzählen? Und so, also gutes System, die beiden spielen sich immer die Bälle hin und her. Ja, kurz, du hast dich gerade so lustig darüber gemacht, dass der Geist des Dalai Lama nur fünf Kilometer reist, max. Ich weiß nicht, ob Geist der richtige buddhistische Begriff ist, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was das ist. Die Identität des Dalai Lama nur fünf Kilometer reist, weil es faul ist, aber ich glaube, als Dalai Lama bist du ja ein guter Mensch. Also du lebst ja, du verkörperst ja die Werte des Buddhismus. Und ist es nicht so, dass du bestraft wirst für schlechte Taten und dann als Wurm wiedergeboren wirst? Wo alle Würmer auch sagen, Leute, we're crawling right here. So, Leute, wir sind auch direkt unter euch.
Wir hören alles, was ihr sagt, extrem laut.
Jede Vibration, dieses
ich will kein Wurm werden, bitte kein Wurm werden.
Leute, hallo, sorry, ich hänge
direkt an deinem Haken dran. Wir hängen hier
rundum, ist eh schon nicht
schön. Nee, ist unangenehm, vor allem
das Problem. Aber die werden ja kein Wurm,
das meine ich nur. Der Dalai Lama wird
kein Igel, kein Wurm, kein Surfer, du aus fucking Hawaii, nein, der wird ja in der Umgebung geboren, weil da die Leute geboren werden, die ... Mein Problem ist eher, du steigst ja auf durch ein moralisch gutes Leben und steigst ab durch ein moralisch schlechtes Leben. Aber angenommen, du verhaust jetzt ein Leben, weil ich meine, wenn du wirklich buddhistisch denkst, dann ist ja ein Leben halt so ein Level so. Dann denkst du dir, Fark, das kannst du mal verhauen. Das ist ja ein Schuljahr, du kannst mal sitzen bleiben. Spannende Frage, gibt es mehr Selbstmorde in ... Ich glaube, Selbstmord ist ein dickes Minus. Da bist du sofort auf Molch oder weniger. Nee, aber wenn ich jetzt halt ... Guck mal, ob du da Bock drauf. Wenn ich mal wieder GTA anschmeisse, so, dann ... Und ich bin nicht mehr so in der Story drin und denke mir, jetzt einfach mal Quatsch machen. Dann mache ich Quatsch, sterbe und dann lebe ich ja wieder. So muss sich ja so ein Buddhist auch so ein bisschen fühlen. Nee, nee, nee, ich glaube, das sind so die verschiedenen Loop-Holes, die wurden getestet und die funktionieren nicht. Das ist wie wenn du, du kannst ja beim Christen auch nicht sagen, Gott, vergib mir eh alles, deswegen darf ich machen, was ich will. Man kann ziemlich genau das sagen. Nee, bitte nicht, macht das bitte nicht. Also da hat der Papst, glaube ich, 1603 auch gesagt, sorry Leute, Gentleman's Agreement, ja, Gott vergibt euch technisch gesehen alles, aber jetzt macht, seid halt trotzdem halt... Gentulum agremientum. Lasst es einfach. Das Gentleman's Agreement. Ja, kann gut sein, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach gegen die Regeln. So, jetzt ist aber das Problem. Angenommen, du verhaust jetzt ein Leben so richtig, so fuck, wirklich von der ersten Minute an, du klaust wo man kann. So wie du deins. Naja, ich... So wie du deins. Okay, okay. Und jetzt, okay, du merkst schon gegen Ende des Lebens, fuck, ich habe alles versaut. Ich kann jetzt nicht noch letzte Stunde Referat halten, um irgendwie die Note hochzudrücken, das war's. So, und dann bist du halt irgendwie Igel. Und wie sieht jetzt ein gutes Leben eines Igels aus, damit du wieder hochkommst? Ich glaube, je tiefer du failst, desto weniger kannst du auch falsch machen, also als so eine Mikrobe. Da kannst du nicht so viel, du kannst, zeig mir eine Arschloch-Mikrobe. Naja, du kannst irgendwie Krebszellen fressen oder so, das ist gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob du so viel Wahl hast als Mikrobe. Ich glaube, die Chance, dass du weiter, dass du noch in der vierten Liga nochmal absteigst mit dem ersten FC Florentin, glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Aber ich meine, jeder kennt doch Arschlochtiere, oder? Jeder kennt, es sagen doch sogar Leute, die ein Haustier haben, sagen, meine Katze ist ein Arschloch. Ja gut, aber als Katze bist du ja schon sehr nah am Menschen mit daran. Doch, du bist schon weiter aufgestiegen. Aber die Katze ist auf dem Weg nach unten. Die ist auf dem Weg nach unten. Die ist wirklich auf dem Weg nach unten. Die wird so ein schöner Hamster. Ja genau, die geht dann nochmal runter. Immer weniger Gehirnkapazität. Und irgendwann ist so wenig Gehirnkapazität, dass du auch kein Arschloch mehr sein kannst. It takes brain to be an asshole. Okay, und einer der wichtigsten Glaubenssätze des Buddhismus. Das ist Stephanismus. So, und jetzt, okay, aber grundsätzlich, Panchen Lama, Dalai Lama werfen sich über die Jahrtausende den Ball hin und her, finden sich gegenseitig wieder. Weil, ah, da bist du, weil die kennen, das sind ja, also wenn man jetzt mal wirklich sagt, das sind so reinkarnierte Wesen, die kennen sich dann irgendwann und ah, ich seh schon, ehrlich gesagt, mega geil, was eine jetzt schon für eine coole MVP-Religion. Mega gut, mega gut, funktioniert, ich bin jetzt auch bereit, die Zensur zu geben und meine fällt ähnlich positiv aus wie deine. Bis irgendjemand das System durchschaut hat und sagt, nee, pass auf, wir entführen den Panchen Lama. Hat wer den Panchen Lama entführt? Ja, der wurde entführt. Kürzlich? Hat jemand kürzlich den Panchen Lama? Der aktuelle Panchen Lama ist von der chinesischen Regierung entführt worden und ist weg. Und jetzt haben die ein richtiges Problem. Weil, solange der Panchen Lama nicht da ist, in dem Moment, in dem der Dalai Lama tot ist, hat diese gesamte Religion ein Riesenproblem, weil es kann kein neuer Dalai Lama benannt werden, weil der Panchen Lama nicht da ist. Aber wenn der Panchen Lama wirklich der grosse Macker ist, für den er sich verkauft.
Nee, nee, das war ein kleiner Junge. Der Dalai Lama hat gesagt, pass auf, du bist jetzt Panchen Lama, achtjähriger Junge oder so, nächste Woche weg, entführt. Die chinesische Regierung sagt, nee, nee, nee, der will nur in Abgeschottetheit leben, der will nicht an die Öffentlichkeit, dem geht's gut. gängiger Wunsch eines achtjährigen Kindes, im Exil abgeschottet von der Öffentlichkeit zu leben, aber trotzdem, Yu-Gi-Oh-Karten hätte ich trotzdem gerne. We've all been there, ja. Jeder hat als, ich weiß nicht, aber acht, das ist ungefähr der Bereich. So, und jetzt ist halt Schachmat. Jetzt ist halt wirklich bestätig. Die haben die ganze Religion Schachmat gesetzt. Ja, ja. Ich meine, natürlich ist es... Endlich spielst du meine Sprache, ich verstehe genau, was du meinst. Ja, ich dachte, du leuchtest auf. Ich meine, wir verurteilen das natürlich. Das Podcast-Ufo, glaube ich, verurteilt dieses ... Nein, weiß ich nicht. Wir sind gegen Kidnapping von Sprüchen überhaupt. Nein? Wir sind, weiß ich nicht, wir sind auf jeden Fall, ich will jetzt auch keine andere Religion bevorzugen. Das Podcasthof ist gegen Gewalt. Nein, ich sag jetzt mal was, ich hau jetzt mal mit der Faust auf den Tisch. Nee, ich sag mal, manchmal muss man für Wahrheiten auch gerade stehen. Ich bin gegen die Entführung von Kindern. So. Wo ist der Shitstorm? Nee. Ich bin bereit, ihn anzudenken. Nein, ich bin gegen die Entführung von kleinen Kindern. Okay, dafür komme ich gerne an den Preis. Das ist Blonis Worte, den ich meine. Dafür gehe ich gerne an den Preis. So, und jetzt haben die ein Problem. Tolle Geschichte auf jeden Fall. Vielen Dank an alle, die mich darauf hingewiesen haben, dass unser dummes Paul-Drehbuch tatsächlich realweltliche Konsequenzen hat. Innspannender.pannender. Und das ist jetzt wirklich ein Krimi. Weil vor allem die Chinesen haben jetzt einen neuen Panchen Lama benannt, aber der wird jetzt halt so halb akzeptiert, weil die sagen, nee, der andere, wo ist denn der andere? So, und jetzt ist das halt schwierig und ja, spannend. Das ist ja interessant. Aber kann man relativ wenig eingreifen. Aber wenn ihr den findet, falls ihr den irgendwo in der Gegend habt, helft dem. Wird denn die ganze, da wird ja auch so Tibet, China und so wird ja auch alles ausgefochten wahrscheinlich über so einen Konflikt. Absolut, ja das ist das Problem. Man weiss nicht so viel darüber leider. Man weiss nicht so viel darüber, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein politisch angespanntes Thema und ich bin gespannt, wie es weitergeht in der letzten Staffel. Lernen wir alles in Antenne anderer Religion. Finde ich auch gut. Das war der Podcast UFO Korrektur. Ja, Korrektur oder eher so ein Add-on. Add-on, Fanfiction. Fanfiction, nee. Weiter geht's. Weiter geht's, aber jetzt geht's weiter mit der normalen Folge.
Ja, also das nur als kurzer Ausschnitt und eine ganz andere Sache, die wir noch ganz kurz abfrühstücken können, ist, weil wir haben letzte Woche behauptet, es gäbe... Das wird albern, das wird einfach albern.
Wir haben letzte Woche behauptet, dass noch nie ein Mensch tatsächlich geschaut hat, nachdem er gesagt hat, mal schauen. Wir haben gesagt, man sagt so oft, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, müssen wir mal schauen. Und unsere Theorie war These, niemand hat danach wirklich mal geguckt. Hat mal jemand nachgeguckt, hat mal jemand geschaut? Nein. Wir haben gesagt, nein, niemand hat jemals danach tatsächlich nachgeschaut, bis sich Johannes gemeldet hat. Hat Johannes nachgeschaut, hat er mal geguckt? Und Johannes schreibt, ich bin jemand, der diese Redewendung schauen wir einfach mal oder mal schauen tatsächlich recht oft verwendet und meistens führt auch kein Weg dran vorbei, da dann wirklich nochmal zu schauen. Denn, Johannes, das liegt daran, dass ich in meinem Beruf, Softwareentwickler, nie zum Anfang des Projekts alle notwendigen Informationen habe und wirklich schauen muss, wie sich die Gegebenheiten beispielsweise auf die Software auswirken. Ja, das ist, oh scheiss, eine sehr gute Erklärung. Ich glaube, wer das, Johannes. Also wir haben haben den einzigen Menschen gefunden, der tatsächlich dann auch mal schaut. Ja, oder eine Gruppe, die einzige Berufsgruppe gefunden, die das wirklich auch mal sagen kann, ohne dass man als Kunde sofort denkt, der wird jetzt mit dir schauen. Wir können jetzt einen anderen suchen. Also Softwareentwickler sind Menschen, die tatsächlich dann auch mal gucken. Wenn Fliesenleger... Ich dachte, du meldest dich. Ich wollte mich nicht melden, nein, mit dem Pulli. Wenn Fliesenleger zu mir sagt, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, wollen wir mal gucken, wollen wir das mal haben. Vergiss es, du kannst den Nächsten suchen, du rufst den nächsten Fliegenleger an. Fliesenleger. So, bei dem. Der fliegende Fliesenleger. Der fliegende Fliesenleger, Fliegelin. Nein, wenn jetzt Softwareentwickler sagen, ja, da müssen wir mal gucken, weiss ich jetzt, okay, gut, guckt mal, ihr guckt wirklich nochmal. Da passiert wirklich was. Da wird noch gearbeitet. Ja, cool, also ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass es auf die meisten Fälle immer noch zutrifft, hätte ich gesagt. Nee, absolut. Also, ich kann nur über mich sprechen, aber ich habe noch nie geschaut. Ich habe gesagt, ja, wir müssen ja gucken. Müssen wir dann mal gucken, zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt. Ja, also maximal viel Relativfüge. Aber du kannst doch jetzt gucken. Nee, dann müssen wir dann mal gucken. Dann müssten wir dann mal gucken. Wir müssten dann mal gucken. Wir könnten ja mal dann gucken. Also es ist so nah an Nein, dass es eigentlich Nein ist. Es gibt diesen Helge-Schneider-Ausschnitt aus dem Film von ihm, ich weiß nicht aus welchem Film, wo jemand sagt, ich könnte mich nicht erinnern. Es gibt manchmal in Deutschland so einen Konjunktiv, den man einfach ganz gerne mal benutzt. Wenn du sagst, das hast du doch gesagt, dann kann man durchaus im Ruhrgebiet, glaube ich, sagen, ich könnte mich nicht erinnern, da ich das gesagt habe. Aber was daran total toll ist, ist, man sagt, ich versuche gar nicht, mich daran zu erinnern. Selbst wenn ich mich daran erinnern wollte, ich könnte mich nicht daran erinnern. Man distanziert sich maximal weit weg von dieser blöden Behauptung. Ich könnte mich nicht erinnern. Könnte ich mich erinnern, würde ich es tun, aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern. Könnte ich mich daran erinnern, würde ich es tun, würde es ja aber nicht sagen, könnte ich mich erinnern. Wollte ich mich erinnern, könnte ich es wollen, aber ich will nicht. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Konjunktiv ohnehin eine meiner Lieblings. Können wir mal den Kasus der Woche küren? Kasus der Woche Teil 1. Ist Konjunktiv ein Kasus? Platz Nummer 8. Ja, nee. Konjunktiv ist ein, ähm, eine, äh, Verb, Verbart. Fall, ein Fall? Nee, eine Konjunktiv. Nee, Kasus und Fall ist dasselbe, glaub ich. Das ist das Gleiche. Nominativ, Genitiv, Dativ, Akkusativ, Ablativ und Nominativ. Wow. So, das ist das eine. So, haben wir das schon mal. Jetzt ist aber Konjunktiv und Indikativ sind ... Das war der Kasus der Woche, oche, oche, oche. Ist schwierig. Was hast du so erlebt? Bist du durch die Welt gelaufen? Was hast du gemacht, wo bist du gewesen? Ich bin durch die Welt gelaufen, nicht viel, nicht weit, ich hab mich nicht weit bewegt. Da würde man so eine Hitzekarte von mir machen. Sehr viel Hitze. Kochend heiß an einem Ohr. Kochend heiß vor meinem Rechner. Ansonsten eher kalt. Aber ansonsten, ich habe viel bestellt. Ich habe für mich tatsächlich entdeckt, und tatsächlich der Begriff Guilty Pleasure nimmt bei mir mittlerweile echt obskure Züge an. Weil mittlerweile ist es mein Guilty Pleasure, mir ein paar gefrorene Erbsen warm zu machen.
Gefrorene Erbsen warm machen.
Das ist so wirklich, wenn man so Wenn der Guilty Pleasure was wird,
wo man sich nicht mehr schuldig fühlen muss, sondern was einem
aktiv hilft, ein besseres Leben zu führen,
ist es dann noch ein Guilty Pleasure? Ja, ich denke mir so,
also ich habe mich letztens bei dem Gedanken erwischt,
als ich so irgendwie acht Uhr abends
oder so, ich hatte schon zu Abend gegessen und
dann irgendwie mir dachte,
ach jetzt komm, jetzt machst du ja noch ein paar Erbsen, jetzt ist ja auch mal gut, jetzt lässt du Ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der, ich bin der,ends oder so, ich hatte schon zu Abend gegessen und dann irgendwie mir dachte, ach jetzt komm, jetzt machst du ja noch ein paar Erbsen, jetzt ist es auch mal gut, jetzt lässt du doch auch mal zwölf gerade sein, du lebst nur einmal, du bist ein Junge, du hast auch viel geschafft heute, lass es dir mal gut gehen. Man muss sein Leben auch genießen können, wozu macht man den Kram denn? Ja, jetzt kann man mir eine Wohnung leisten, aber was hilft mir das denn, wenn ich nichts draus mache? jetzt mach dir doch mal ein paar Erbsen, mein Junge. Und dann habe ich mir ein paar Erbsen in den Topf und denke mir, das ist der Höhepunkt deines Hedonismus, das ist dein Rausch, das ist dein Dionysos-Moment, wo du mal wirklich aus dir herausgehst, sind ein paar Erbsen. Was ist passiert bis dahin? Ich bin abgestiegen. Warum Erbsen? Ich weiss nicht, aber irgendwie habe ich für mich gefrorene Erbsen entdeckt und ich habe Bock drauf, weil du hast so einen ganzen fucking Beutel, so einen Kilo Beutel. Die sind klein. Die sind so klein und so fucking hart. Und das ist irgendwie so, weil du kannst dir, ich schnipp dann auch manche so aus dem Fenster raus, so schnippen. Klar, ich habe mir schon gedacht, dass es irgendwo solche Züge annimmt, aber also du machst sie schon warm. Du ist sie nicht gefroren. Und ich bin einfach begeistert von dieser Kälte, das reizt mich. Du machst sie kalt, ich mache die warm und dann lasse ich sie abkühlen. Und dann heu ich sie nochmal in den Gefrierstern. Und dann frierst du sie wieder ein. Und dann isst du sie. Weil im Grunde, da ist so viel Minusenergie in dieser Kälte. Das saugt so. Du machst das warm und dann bleibt es erstmal kalt. Und dann machst du, komm, jetzt drehe ich den auf drei hoch. Aber führ uns dann mal so durch so einen wohligen Genießerabend von Florentin. Ja, oh Gott, natürlich. Also jetzt mal an alle Zuhörer da draußen. Man kann sich mal was gönnen, aber wirklich, mach das mit Vorsicht. Also ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie dann, die Podcast-Ufer hat gesagt, ich kann jeden Abend Erbsen essen und dann werden die Leute ungesund. Ja, nee, da hat niemand Bock drauf. Also wir haben eine gewisse Verantwortung, da auch eine Warnung, also jetzt wirklich eine Genusswarnung, das ist was für einmal im Monat vielleicht. Ja, aber ohne Scheiß, da müsst ihr euch auch mal wirklich was gönnen. Ja, das gehört genauso dazu, der Cheat-Dank gehört genauso dazu. Und wenn ich mal abends denke, Mensch, jetzt kann auch mal Mensch sein, du bist doch keine Maschine, du kannst doch nicht immer nur effizienzgetrieben durch die Welt gehen, nein, du musst doch auch mal genießen. dir. Dieser Fleischsack. Dieses Maschinenhafte, dich an Tageszeiten, hocheffiziente, ehrgeizige, wo auch wenig Menschlichkeit fehlt. Das kennt man von dir. Nein, so der Mensch, du bist ja nicht nur Computer, du bist doch nicht nur virtuell, du hast ja auch einen Körper. Du kannst ja auch sinnliche Lust, sinnlichen Genuss erleben. Wo ist das hin, wo ist das hin? Wo ist das denn hin? Und dann sage ich,
jetzt lass mich auch mal Mensch sein
und dann hole ich den Sack,
den ein Kilo Sack. Den ein Kilo
Sack. Den Plastik
Sack, gefrorene Erbsen
und erst mal dann schön in den Topf rieseln
lassen. Das ist ein
Schlagzeug-Solo für die Seele.
Erst mal reinrieseln
lassen und die sind so hart. Und ich denke mir immer, wow, wann wurden die gefroren und dann wo sind die genau?
Wann geht das Geli-Petterding bei dir los, das Gefühl genau? Jetzt schon? Ich hätte jetzt schon ehrlich wieder Bock. Ich hätte jetzt Bock. Nee, nee, nee, ich mein, in dem Moment, wo du das in den Kopf rieseln lässt, ist das schon Teil der ganzen Seelenmassage?
Ja, das ist ein multisinnliches Erlebnis.
Und vor allem, ich bin ja sehr ungeduldig.
Und klar, ist dann auch schon mal eine ...
Aber kann man mal sein.
Kann man mal sein.
Ja, gönnt das euch doch mal.
Und dann ist natürlich, ich will nicht leugnen,
ist auch manchmal schon eine gefrorene Erbse,
auch im gefrorenen Zustand in meinen Mund hineingestolpert.
Geprasselt. Geprassasselt und dann wird das aufgelutscht. Und du hast ja ein warm mit Wasser, nein, einfach so. Ja, das ist das Ding. Das war eine Frage, die ich nämlich lange, kann man das einfach in den Topf tun und wärmen? Und er stellt sich raus, ja, das geht. Man kann das aufwärmen. Und weil ich habe oft immer noch ein bisschen Spinat dazu getan, so ein paar Brocken Spinat, also wenn ich mal ganz wild bin. Oh, aber das sind... Du musst schon viel geleistet haben an so einem Tag. Bisschen Spinat, weil Spinat... Kann mal jemand Spinat erklären? Weil wenn du so Spinat im Tiefkopf weißt, was Spinat du, was Spinat für mich sind? Wenn ich so, als Kind habe ich manchmal so Dino-Filme gesehen, so Dino-Reportagen. Und dann gab es also diese Pflanzenfresse, die einfach mal in so einen Baum gebissen haben. Ja. Und dieses Urverlangen, mal einfach so ein Blatt zu essen, das ist doch Spinat. So wegrupfen und einfach mal aufschnappen. Niemand kann mir erzählen, dass Spinat geil schmeckt. Nee, einfach mal Pferd sein. Einfach mal Pferd sein. Das ist doch so die Basic-Form von einfach mal Baum essen. Ja. Das ist für mich Spinat. Auch Brokkoli, für mich immer kleine Bäume, die ich wegschnabuliere. Ich esse einen Baum jetzt. Einen ganzen Baum. Weil, also, welchen Zustand hat Spinat? Welcher Aggregatszustand ist Spinat? Weil wenn du den Spinat warm machst, dann ist es doch eine Flüssigkeit. Das ist doch so ein Maschmus. Ja, ich glaube, es ist genau dazwischen. Aber warum ist das so flüssig? Wasser. Aber warum Wasser? Wasser in dem Blatt. Aber das ist doch ... Moment, also das ...
Spinat dann wird zerhäckselt, dann kommt das Wasser raus, haut ab, wird dann aber schnell weggefroren und ist dann noch in dem Brocken, weil du hast ja so kleine Bröckchen Spinat, so Zeug. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das richtig ist. Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich bin gerade bei echten Spinat als Blattform, die man so in den Pfannen macht. Nee, nee, nee, ich bin bei Tiefkühlspinat. Ja, das habe ich gemerkt jetzt. Weil es gibt ja auch so diesen gehackten Jungspinat, der dann eben keine Flüssigkeit ist, sondern halt Blätter. Aber der klassische Spinat, den man isst, wenn man meint, ich esse Spinat, der isst ja eine Flüssigkeit. Der isst basically Flüssigkeit. Warum? Was ist da drin, was bei dem anderen nicht drin ist? Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Und so auf jeden Fall, weil ich dachte mir, bei den Erbsen, ich hatte erst Angst, weil natürlich als Mathematiker denkt er... Erbsen-Urangst. Man denkt natürlich als Mathematiker, Sekunde, wie hoch ist denn jetzt die Auflagefläche einer Kugel auf einer Fläche? Unendlich klein. Jetzt wenn diese Fläche erhitzt wird... Sagst du so, als wäre das ob jetzt die Antwort, bin ich mir schon nicht so sicher. Aber irgend so was in der Ecke. Es tendiert gegen unhitzig wahrscheinlich. So eine richtig krasse Kugel. Richtig so Radius 1. So motherfucking 1. Riesig grosse Kugel vor. Ich glaube, es ist egal, wie gross die Kugel ist. Perfekte, riesige, nur für das Gedankenexperiment muss sie gerade unendlich gross sein. Warum? Planetengross. Okay. So eine unendlich große silberne Kugel. Okay. So chrom, so verkromte? Verchromte Kugel. Oh, geil. Und jetzt stell dir die glatteste Oberfläche der Welt vor. Ja. Einfach eine Kilometer lange, wie Fussballfelder über Fussballwälder, große, glatte Feld. Nein, nein, nein. Okay. So, und dann legst du die Kugel, wird langsam runtergelassen auf diese spiegelglatte Fläche. Woran hängt die? Magneten oder hat die so ein Harnisch? Hat ein Harnisch. Geschirr und auf einem grossen Kran, oder wie? So, grosser Kran, Harnisch, wird langsam runtergelassen. Ja. So, wie gross ist die Fläche, auf der Sie sich berühren? Ich würde sagen, unendlich klein. Aber du kannst mich gerne widerlegen. Nee, aber jetzt wäre ich gerade nämlich auch bei unendlich klein. Es ist super klein. So, und jetzt überlegen wir uns natürlich, was ist, wenn diese riesige Fläche jetzt plötzlich heiß wird. Jetzt überträgt sich ja die Hitze, ja, wie heiß, sagen wir mal so 100 Grad, 100.000 Grad, 100.000 Grad. Und jetzt musst du ja multiplizieren, 1000 Grad mal unendlich kleine Fläche ist gleich null. Unendlich krasse Kälte. Null. Nee, unendlich Kälte. So. Ja, basically null. Ach, du meinst, wenn du, ach so, 80 Grad mal null ist null Grad, ist dann wieder kalt. Wie kalt ist denn diese riesige Erbse? Tiefgefroren, schockgefroren, bibberig. Ich glaube, Unschein ist, dass die spiegelnde Fläche eher kalt wird,
als dass die Erbse in diesem Ratio, ich weiß nicht, ob der uns jetzt hilft gerade,
aber es ist halt eine riesig grosse Kugel.
Sonst wäre ich bei deiner Meinung, die Erbsen werden nicht heiß.
Und das nächste, die werden heiß, aber an einem unendlich kleinen Punkt.
Der wird verbrannt.
Genau, jetzt denke ich mir nämlich, wie oft muss man die Erbse jetzt wenden, damit die gesamte Oberfläche warm ist. Unendlich mal. Genau, man muss sie unendlich oft wenden. Und jetzt sitze ich da und denke mir, ich habe nicht so viel Zeit. Ich habe nur, ich will meine Erbsen in fünf Minuten wegnaschen, ich kann die jetzt nicht unendlich Stunden hin und her wenden, damit jeder unendlich kleine Punkt auf dieser Kugel warm ist.
Vor allem, damit nur nicht jeder unendlich kleine Punkt dieser einen Erbse warm wird, sondern alle zehntausend Erbsen, die man im Topf hat. Und dann denke ich mir, das hast du endlich mal tausend, mal Stunden.
Und dann denke ich mir, in dem Moment, in dem du einfach ein bisschen Flüssigkeit in den Topf tust, löst sich dieses Problem völlig auf. Flüssigkeit erhitzt sich. Flüssigkeit erhitzt sich, erhitzt die Erbse zu voll. Unendlich mal Fläche auf der Erbse. Genau, weil jetzt hast du nämlich die volle Fläche der Kugel, von allen Seiten ballert die Wärme rein, sofort weich und dann mischt du du durch. Und deswegen war ich, wie du zu Recht, deine Intuition war da völlig richtig, zu sagen, kann man dann einfach kugelförmige Dinge auf einer Platte garen? Und anscheinend gegen die Erkenntnisse der Mathematik geht das. Und das hat mich erschüttert. Die Mathematik hat mich erneut in den Rücken getreten, hat mir erneut das Bein gestellt und hat gesagt, in der Reihenfolge. Weil es sind keine guten Bullis, es sind gute Mathematiker, aber es sind sehr schlechte. Es ist ein Bleistift aus der Tasche gefallen, sorry. Und es geht aber, und deswegen habe ich nämlich immer ein bisschen Spinat erst reingetan, um ein gewisses Spinatbett zu erzeugen. Okay, du hast quasi, sehr kompliziert, du hast quasi Wasser, von dem wir nicht genau wissen, was es ist, dafür genutzt. Ja genau, es ist eine merkwürdige Masse, ich glaube physikalisch uneinig, physikalisch mit zwei Füssen in zwei Kategorien stehend, fest und flüssig gleichzeitig und jetzt bin ich aber umgestiegen nur auf Erbsen und jetzt mache ich meine Erbsen direkt, mache ich die schön warm und dann klar, kann da ein bisschen Salz und Pfeffer drauf. Ja sag mal, wer bin ich aber umgestiegen, nur auf Erbsen, und jetzt mache ich meine Erbsen direkt, mache ich die schön warm und dann, klar, kann da ein bisschen Salz und Pfeffer drauf. Oh Gott. Ja, sag mal, wer bin ich denn? Natürlich! Aber ey, ich finde es total schön, dich so glücklich zu sehen und zu wissen, du hast dich gefunden, du hast gefunden, was du magst, das gefunden, wie du dich belohnen kannst. Das freut mich total, zu wissen, dir geht es gut, du bist gut aufgehoben. Ja, aber ich fände natürlich auch besser, wenn es ein bisschen was Aufregenderes wäre, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Echt? Ich würde natürlich auch, also ich denke mir schon auch so, wow, weil vor allem, ich bin dann richtig, das ist so wie wenn du als Kind noch irgendwie eine Tüte Chips in deinem Zimmer schmuggelst. Das ist das Gefühl, was du hast. Eine Tüte Chips in deinem Zimmer schmuggelst. Dieses Gefühl, als ob du eine Tüte Chips in deinem Zimmer schmuggelst. Genau, dieses, Ich gucke mich um, hoffentlich erwischt mich niemand beim Erbsenkochen.
Hoffentlich kein Mathematiker, weil das gibt Ärger.
Nee, dann würde es sofort nicht mehr funktionieren.
Dann würde es nicht mehr funktionieren.
Und deswegen habe ich schon noch so ein bisschen diese verruchte Atmosphäre, dieses Erwischt mich jemand und dann wird es wegschnabuliert.
Frage, überwiegt, da musst du dich jetzt kurz konzentrieren für die Frage, überwiegt die Scham darüber, dass du gerade sich darüber freust, Erbsen zu kochen oder überwiegt die Freude, Erbsen zu kochen? Die Scham macht die Freude noch größer, weil es ist ein doppeltes Verbot. Exponentierte Scham? Ja, nee, wir haben eigentlich Scham mal Verbot ist gleich Freude Quadrat. Also, Scham mal Verbot. Richtig. Verbot? Von wem kommt Verbot? Ja, das ist, nee, Scham über Verbot. Also Scham durch Verbot. Ja, je grösser das Verbot, nee, je grösser das Verbot, desto, ne, eigentlich müssen wir Verbot durch Scham ist gleich Freude. Hoch zwei. Also je höher, also je mehr es verboten ist, desto mehr Spaß macht es. Ja. Und je mehr man sich dafür schämt, desto weniger, aber das stimmt glaube ich nicht. Bei mir wäre es anders. Ne, du hast Verbot mal Scham. Weil Verbot und Scham ist doch eigentlich dasselbe. Scham ist die Reaktion aufs Verbot. Aber wir können ja sagen, Verbot ist ein äusseres Verbot und Scham ist ein inneres Verbot, weil du schämst dich vor dir selber primär, wohingegen Verbot heißt, eine andere Instanz verbietet es dir. Also deine Eltern verbieten dir, Chips zu essen, daher kommt Verbot. Gut, es muss gut sein. Wir können ja sagen, Verbot Quadrat mal Scham ist gleich Freude. Wurzel Freude. Ist gleich Wurzel Freude. Und dann sagst du, hast du noch den inneren Charm, der bei mir natürlich enorm ist. Verbot recht klein, Verbot ist so 0,1. Verbot ist 0,1 Quadrat. Nee, ist gen unendlich. Ist negativ vielleicht. Nee, gen null, meine ich.
Gen null.
Und scheiß die Scham darüber, Erbsen noch zu essen, das Verbot Erbsen zu essen, strebt extrem gen null. Ja, okay. Niemand verbietet die Erbsen zu essen. Also strebt rasant gen null. Genau. Limes? also-Verbot mal, und jetzt die Scham ist nämlich gar nicht so trivial, die Scham, dich über Erbsen zu freuen, ist Freude durch Scham. Das ist es nämlich. Aha, Limes-Verbot-Quadrat ist gleich Freude durch Scham. Wurzel. Ja. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich glaube, wir haben es. Ich glaube, wir haben es.
Wir schalten kurz zu den Mathematikern. Mathematiker haben den Raum verlassen. Und ja, das macht mir auf jeden Fall grosse Freude und ärgerlich für mich, dass ich das noch nicht so früh entdeckt habe, weil ich habe das erst seit einem kurzen Entdeckt, Erbsen für mich, und mittlerweile genieße ich das total. Wie dann brauchst du dann so für hundert Erbsen? Und daraus die Ableitung. Eigentlich brauchst du die Ableitung von der Erbsenfunktion. Um die Geschwindigkeit, die Geschwindigkeit, in der du Erbsen hast, ist die erste Ableitung von der Zeit, die du brauchst für Hunde und Erbsen. Ja, aber ist gut. Und ich mag auch irgendwie dieses Löffeln, also dieses Reinlöffeln. Ich glaube, wir sind alle geprägt von Old Shatterhand mit seinem Riesenteller Bohnen. So einfach sich was reinlöffeln, das hat, glaube ich, sowas. Also nicht dieses Messergabel. Ich glaube, der Löffel, also These, der Mensch hatte den Löffel, bevor er die Gabel hatte. These bestätigt. Danke. Damit ist der Löffel, greift was Urzeitliches an, so was Essen aus Hunger, so was Weglöffelndes. Die Gabel ist ja eher ein Genussinstrument. Auch immer so eine heiße Suppe mit so einem Holzlöffel, mit so einem grossen. Oh ja, und da sind noch Brocken drin. Oh ja, jetzt sind wir bei Herr der Ringe, glaube ich. Ja, bei Extended Edition. Wir sind bei Herr der Ringe, die zwei Türme, Extended Edition, wo Eowyn Aragon eine Suppe macht, die ihm nicht schmeckt. Warum schmeckt sie ihm nicht? Weil Eowyn natürlich nicht in ihre Rolle als Hausfrau, als Frau in der Kultur passen war. Ah ja, natürlich!
Der Film zeigt dir, Udi erfüllt ihre Rolle nicht gut,
die muss aus ihrer Rolle ausbrechen. Natürlich!
Um dann natürlich mit den Männern in den Krieg
zu reiten. Aber, Extended Edition
hat man gesagt, weg, weg damit.
Da erfährt man übrigens auch, dass Aragon
80 Jahre alt ist. Das wusste ich auch.
Ich glaube, immer habe ich,
ohne zu wissen, die Extended-Inversion geguckt. Und es ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm, das zuzugeben. Aber die nächste Phase ist am Horizont. Meine nächste ... Oh nein, ich dachte, Schach ist was Ernstes. Ihr passt so gut zusammen, Schach und du. Ihr passt so gut zusammen, ihr hattet so viel Spaß zusammen. Wir bleiben Freunde. Wir bleiben Freunde. Schach und ich bleiben Freunde. Du brauchst mal was Festes endlich. Warum brauch ich was Festes? Schach und ich bleiben Freunde. ist, ihr habt euch so gut zusammen, ihr hattet so viel Spaß zusammen, ihr wart zusammen im Fernsehen. Wir bleiben Freunde, wir bleiben Freunde. Ach nein, Stefan, du brauchst mal was Festes endlich. Warum bleibst du was Festes endlich? Schach und ich bleiben Freunde. Du brauchst was Festes, ihr habt euch so gut verstanden, in ein paar Jahren wirst du dir denken. Wir verstehen uns immer noch. Ja, aber... Wir sehen uns auch regelmäßig. Ja, das sagst du jetzt, aber du weißt doch, dass ihr in ein paar Wochen keinen Kontakt mehr habt. Ich habe jedenfalls eine neue Phase. Ich habe eine neue. Mann, ihr wart so toll zusammen, mit Jan Gustafsson, war so stolz auf euch. Und du hattest diese Weste an. Ich habe mich schick gemacht für Schach. Wir haben einen schönen Abend gehabt. Nein, du musst dich auch mal mehr festsetzen. Du kannst nicht immer weglaufen vor Verantwortung. Ich habe keine Lust mehr, immer vor dir dieses Commitment-Ding zu hören. Weißt du, du und die Gesellschaft... Wo soll das denn führen? Ich will auch nur glücklich sein. Ich werde schon irgendwann bei einer bleiben. Ich will ja auch, dass du glücklich bist, aber ich glaube, es wird dir auch mal gut zu tun, sowas auch mal zu vertiefen. Also, ich gebe dir recht, Schach und ich, wir haben gut zusammengepasst und wir hatten eine schöne Zeit. Aber jetzt ist da diese neue Faser am Horizont. Was ist es jetzt? Hey, warte, warte, warte. Du hattest jetzt Kochen, Schlagzeug, Posaune, Kampffisch, Schach ... Ähm ... Japanisch? Äh, äh, japanisch. So, Schlagzeug war das letzte ... Ich glaub, Schlagzeug, Schach, und jetzt kommt ... Boah, ey, ist schwierig. Ich glaube, es ist irgendwas, was du beim Schachspielen entdeckt hast. Irgendwas in der Richtung, vielleicht was online, vielleicht irgendwie in Richtung Poker oder so, online Poker. Oder auch sowas wie Dart, könnte ich mir auch vorstellen. Du hast dir eine Dart-Scheibe geholt und du spielst jetzt Dart. Das ist lächerlich. Dart ist lächerlich. Segelschein, ich mache einen Segelschein. Meine neue Phase ist das Segeln. Ich hätte überlegt, ich komme aus einer Seefahrerfamilie. Wirklich? Ja, aber habe es selber nie mitgenommen. Was heißt Seefahrerfamilie? Meine Eltern haben Segelscheine, Segelbootscheine und Motorbootscheine und so, haben viel Zeit an der Ostsee verbracht. Vor meiner Zeit hatten die wahnsinnig viel Zeit auf dem Meer verbracht. Mit mir haben sie es verloren, mit einem Kind. Und das habe ich jetzt irgendwie, ich glaube, ich versuche, es ein bisschen nachzuholen, weil ich die Erzählung immer so toll fand und dann habe ich gedacht, ich mache jetzt, weil gerade in diesem Sommer, man kann ja nicht so richtig Urlaub machen, man kann ja nicht so richtig planen. Was meinst du mit die Erzählungen, als seine Mutter von einem Wal angegriffen wurde oder was? Ja, der Kraken, der Riesel der Kraken. Was sind das für Seemanns-Erzählungen, die du mit dem Motorboot an der Ostsee gehörst? Ja, aber was für ein Garn Garn? Ich mag das alles. Alles an dem See mag ich. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, habe ich mir gedacht, warum berührt mich das so, diese ganzen Seemannsgarn oder diese ganze Mythologie? Und dann habe ich so, ich habe mich so selber zugehört und habe die ganze Zeit so einen Satz ein, was die bedeutet, was die See bedeutet. Und dann fiel mir ein, nee, das ist von Jack Sparrow, der sagt, was die Black Pearl bedeutet. Und dann fiel mir ein, ja, es ist auch mein Fandom. Du drehst dich um Flucht der Karibik, um dein ganzes Leben. Es ist auch mein Flucht der Karibik-Fandom. Und vielleicht gehöre ich auf die See. Ich glaube, ich gehöre auf die See. Das kann sein. Ich liebe die du der begnadeste Seefahrer, den die Welt je gesehen hat. Vielleicht wirst du die sieben Weltmeere unter deine Herrschaft reichen. Ich liebe die See. Vielleicht bist du der nächste Schrecken. Und ich habe echt Bock, einen Segelschein zu machen und vielleicht im Sommer ein bisschen auf der See zu verbringen. Welche See? Du sagst immer See so als abstraktes Bild. Die See ist meine neue Liebe. Aber was meinst du denn genau? Zum Beispiel der Atlantik, zum Beispiel die Ostsee, die Nordsee, die ist glaube ich zu krass am Anfang, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Nordsee bezwingen möchte noch am Anfang. Die Ostsee kann man glaube ich bezwingen, ist bezwingbar, Mittelmeer ist bezwingbar, Ostsee ist so ein, ich mache es mal ein bisschen Level 1. Ist auch gut, dass es auf der Welt so Einsteigerlevel gibt oder so. Norden ist es glaube ich extrem hart. Wir gucken mal, aber ich habe jedenfalls sehr viel Lust drauf. Habt ihr auch Lust, einen Segelschein zu machen? Machen wir zusammen. Das heißt aber, du hast jetzt wahrscheinlich dir schon so ein gestreiftes Polohemd gesucht, so eine Kapitänsmütze, wo ist das Tattoo, Anker-Tattoo, zack, tatsächlich, alles ist da. Das P auch schon. Du bist schon bereit. Hatten wir eine Bekanntschaft mit der East India Trading Company, Pirat. Oh, aber so ein Brandzeichen, das tut weh. Captain Jack Sparrow. Würdest du dir so ein, ist es verboten, so in der Tattoo-Szene so Brandzeichen zu machen? Ich glaube, es tut auch mehr weh, oder? Was tut mehr weh, Brandzeichen? Deutlich mehr weh wahrscheinlich als Tattoo. Aber geht auch schneller. Ist es dein Körper? Ich glaube, zu Körperverletzungen kann man seine Zustimmung geben. Dann ist es erlaubt. Ist Tattoo eine zugestimmte Körperverletzung? Ja, aber zum Beispiel zum Mord kannst du nicht deine Zustimmung geben. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich erlaube dir, mich zu töten. Kannibale von Rothenburg. Kannibale von Rotenburg. Wir alle haben die Akteneinsicht. Residenzwald. Oh, Jura und Mathe heute. Mensch, wir sind aber echt im Rundumschlag heute. Jura, Mathe und Seefahrt. Seefahrt, ja. Aber ich breite die Fock aus. Ich lifte die Fock und das Vordersegel. Ich habe mir schon so ein paar Sachen angeschaut. Was ist dein Ziel? Du willst eine kleine Schaluppe, eine schöne Schaluppe, ein Semammestern? Nein, dieser Wunsch wächst schon sehr lange in mir, weil auch ich habe einen Berlin-Kumpel und der hat da auf dem Wannsee ein Segelboot und das ist einfach immer schon das coolste der Welt.
Einfach irgendwo mal so ein kleines Bödelchen irgendwann mal zu haben, finde ich wahnsinnig cool.
Batman hat eine Yacht.
Batman hat eine Yacht, sowas finde ich wirklich geil.
Ich brauche kein eigenes Boot, aber
die Vorstellung, so ein Urlaub
auf so einem Segelboot, finde ich total toll.
Was macht man denn da?
Mein Problem mit Segelboot ist, ja,
cool, Segelhissen, geil,
Flaggehissen, cool, alles, was
gehisst wird, bin ich erstmal dabei.
Okay, Hissen ist mein Ding.
Wenn mir jemand sagen würde, hey, du kannst
hier auf unserem Boot den ganzen Tag hissen, sage ich, bin ich dabei.
Was mir auch gefällt ist, dass es für alles neue Wörter gibt.
Ja, Achtern, Reling, Rehling, Feuerbord, Stockbord, Stockbord, alles hin und her, alles neue Namen, finde ich auch gut. Kiel. Ah, Rumpf.
Immer eine Handbreit Wasser unterm Kiel, wünsche ich dir, sagt man sich.
Und ich denke mir, okay, da ist alles gehisst, alles, was hissbar ist, wurde gehisst.
Wurde gehisst. Und dann fährt man mit einem Karacho, glaube ich. Knoten, ja. Mit einem Knotenkaracho, sticht man in See. Ja. Und dann ist man auf dem See. Auf See. Und dann ... Vor Anker. Was? Dann was? Erst mal, du, offensichtlich liebst du die See nicht so wie ich. Du liebst nicht Vielleicht stimmt das, ja. Du liebst nicht den Sonnenaufgang und den Sonnenuntergang auf See. Nicht so wichtig herum als die See. Keine Spur von Land. Einfach nur zwischen dir und dem nächsten Land sind 500 Seemeilen, nautische Meilen, unter dir der Marianngraben, unter dir ist Kilometer weit nichts.
Ja, aber was machst du? Dann liest du eine Zeitung oder spielst du Pokémon oder was macht man denn dann? Ja, spielst du mal Halkart. Nein, aber das ist doch das Gefühl. Ja, aber was, das verstehe ich nicht, das ist so. Denk doch über dein Leben nach, denk nach. Nein, aber ich werde da nervös. Denk nach, ich werde da nervös, aber dann bist du dann wirklich ganz alleine. Nein, ich würde das ja mit Freunden machen, das ist ja die Idee. Aber das würde mich irritieren, dann mit Leuten auf einem begrenzten Bereich alleine zu sein und dann so, ja, und jetzt habe ich euch schon mal erzählt von einer ganz spannenden Investmentmöglichkeit. Hast du schon, oh nein, Gott, nein, weg, weg, Segel, weg hier. Man überbohrt. Nee, nee, nee, da kriege ich, glaube ich, soziale Platzangst. Okay, okay. Das ist so ein bisschen wie ein Aufzug, wenn im Aufzug mich jemand anspricht und ich sage, ich habe keine Fluchtmöglichkeiten. Aber da kannst du ja in den Dingi, in diese kleinen Boote, mit denen du dann zum Land fährst, da kannst du dich kurz setzen und noch ganz kurz. Was ich will, sind diese altertümlichen Taucheranzüge, wo du so einen kompletten Anzug hast, mit so einer großen Kugel auf dem Kopf. Mach du doch das? Ja, das macheelschein. Ich mache einen altertümlichen Tauchkurs. Und du machst einen altertümlichen Ancient Diving. Ich war ja als Kind in einem Tauchkurs und es gibt drei Stufen von Tauchkurs und wenn du den dritten bestanden hast, dann darfst du auch so mit Flasche tauchen und so. Ich habe den ersten gemacht, ich habe den zweiten gemacht, abgebrochen. Ja, das kann auch passieren beim Segelschein, glaube ich. Kann auch passieren. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall wahnsinnig Lust darauf. Das habe ich immer schon überlegt und es ist, glaube ich, keine neue Phase. Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt den Schein. Das ist jetzt aber ernst, oder wie? Das Schein machen ist vielleicht die Phase. Das ist jetzt die Phase fürs Leben. Nein, es ist ein Hobby. Es soll ein Hobby sein. Ich will nicht alles abbrechen und die Welt umsegeln und das zu meinem neuen Leben machen. Nein. Also ist es eine Phase? Ich denke nicht. Ich denke, es ist mehr so, es ist cool zu haben. Generell, Scheine machen das Leben besser. Noch nie hat jemand gesagt, schade, dass ich den Schein gemacht habe. Nein, genau. Niemand bereut Scheine. Das sind meine zwei Thesen. Niemand bereut den Kauf eines Instrumentes. Hm. Und niemand bereut Scheine. Ja, das stimmt. Ich werde nicht in 20 Jahren da sitzen und sagen, jetzt hab ich Segelschein, wo ich denn damit, dann zerreisse ich den und schmeisse den weg. Dammit! Nochmal! Warum habe ich meinen Fischereibetriebschein gemacht? All die verschwendeten Stunden! Ja. Dann wirft den Schein Wüten auf den Boden. Ins Feuer. Genau, in Kamin. In Kamin. Warum habe ich den Kamin-Schein gemacht? Fucking Pyroschein. Man kann auch Pyroschein machen. Ja, das ist cool. Auf dem Schiff. Das ist richtig. Echt? Auf dem Schifferei-Pyroschein. Du kannst dann da Feuerwerk machen auf dem Schiff?
Nein, du musst für manche Schiffe, die diese Pistolen haben, diese Warn-Leuchtfeuer-Pistolen, dafür musst du einen Pyroschein machen, um auf so einem Boot fahren zu können. Oh, geil. Aber kannst du dann auch andere Schiffe beschießen mit den Pistolen oder Raketenabschieden? Dann wird dir aber der Schein weggenommen. Dann gehst du aber einen Piratenschein. Piratenschein. Ich mein, Stefan,
ich kenn dich und ich weiss,
Stefan,
ich weiss, du bist ein heroischer Typ und ich weiss, du bist noch auf der Suche nach einem Abenteil. Hast du, wenn du diesen und ich möchte, dass du jetzt ehrlich bist, hast du, wenn du diesen Segelschein machst, im Hinterkopf zu einem nur ein Prozent so ein Dunkirk-Szenario, wo es irgendwann heißt, hey, die Royal Navy hat nicht genug Schiffe, wir brauchen jetzt auch private Leute, die unsere Boys aus Dünnkirchen retten. Wir brauchen Captain Tietze. Das immer für diesen einen Moment. Das wusste ich. Ich mache einen Segelschein für den Moment, wo wir sagen, wir brauchen auch Privatleute. Ich mache irgendwann den Flugschein, falls es heißt, an diesem 4. Juli, wenn wir gegen die Aliens kämpfen müssen, brauchen wir jeden von euch. Wir brauchen jeden. Wir brauchen jeden Piloten, der fliegen kann. Und dann sitzt ich da. Auch die Einmotoren. So betrunken und sagt, ich kann fliegen. Was? Und der Raum wird leise und dann schon, ich kann fliegen.
Und meine Kinder so, Papa, nein, du musst das... Doch, lass mich jetzt, lass mich jetzt!
Aber Herr Tietze, Ihnen ist schon klar, dass das eine Mission ist, von der es kein Zurückkehren gibt.
Heute, am 4. Juli, Musik, fahr die Musik hoch, die Musik muss heroischer sein, möchte ich unseren Unabhängigkeitstag feiern. Nein, nicht nochmal das. Soll der Film nochmal an? Hä, wie gut das wäre, wenn man das mal im Film verwenden würde und alle Zuschauer, was, what? Nein, aber du hast schon die Heldenepos im Hintergrund. Immer. Meinst du, dass passiert sowas nochmal? Dass man alle braucht, man braucht alle? Genauso wie wenn irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Mudflat oder so, riesige Schlammflut. Schlammflut. Und man sagen, wir brauchen jeden Bagger im Land. Der Norden Deutschlands ist überschwemmt von Schlamm, irgendwo, genau, ein Unterwasservulkan eruptiert. Erigiert. Und stösst Unmengen an Schlamm aus. Und der Schlamm... Wir schalten kurz zu den Geologen. Stösst Unmengen an Schlacke aus und die Schlacke schiesst einfach, schlackt rate einfach nach Bremerhaven.
Bremerhaven. No Bullshit.
Ganz Bremerhaven ist voll.
Jetzt voll geschlackt und dann steht der Mr. President steht dann auf so einem alten Bagger und sagt,
heute, am 13. März brauchen wir jeden von euch. Jeden. Jeden einzelnen Baggerfahrer, jeden einzelnen Baggerfahrerin, die Kinder mit ihren kleinen Baggern, wir brauchen euch mit den Schaufeln, die Norweger mit ihren Öl. Mr. President, es sind nicht genug Bagger gekommen. Da muss auch ich auf einen Bagger. Aber es ist zu viel Schlacke, zu viel Schlamm. Aber wenn ich am dritten Morgen gen Norden gucke zum Sonnenaufgang, kommt doch noch Gandalf für den Bagger. Er kommt doch mit den Baggern von Rohan. Dann kommt er doch an. Genau, nach drei Tagen, man sieht am Horizont nur die Schaufeln, die Schaufeln gegen den Sonnenaufgang. Sie sind gekommen. Die Schaufeln, sie sind da, sie sind gekommen. Das ist kein Orkhorn. Das ist das Ruox.. Ja, na, na, na, na, na.
Und dann müssen alle Baggerfahrer aus ganz Deutschland fahren hin und graben Bremerhaven aus.
Das ist ein guter Film.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Aber auch da, glaube ich, jeder, der einen Baggerschein macht, denkt, eines Tages wird diese Schaufel zu grösserem Fahrerschein.
Oh ja.
Gabelstapler Fahrerschein. Ja, Gabelstapler FahrSchein macht, denkt, eines Tages wird diese Schaufel zu grösserem Fahrerschein. Oh ja. Gabelstapler-Fahrerschein. Ja, Gabelstapler-Fahrerschein. Kasse B. Ich blick auch nicht durch. ISS ist abgestürzt, liegt auf dem Boden. Und ihr sagt es mir auf dem Boden. Wir brauchen alle Gabelstapler, um dieses massive, wuchtige Ding hochzuheben. Wieder ins Weltall zu heben. Aber ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, Elon Musk baut ja die ganze Zeit diese riesen, lächerlich grossen Raketen, um jetzt perspektivisch wieder Space Shuttle ins Weltall zu katapultieren und, keine Ahnung, halt auch Satelliten und sowas. Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, das ist die beste Idee immer noch, um Dinge ins All zu ... Das ist seit den 80ern, 70ern. Hat mal jemand versucht, Dinge ins All zu heben? Ja, einen Aufzug. Mit einer genug grossen Hebebühne? Oder, was ich auch dachte, wenn man so zwei grosse, so Grashalm-artige, ganz filigrane, hohe Stangen macht. und dann ist da dran so ein gespanntes Gummiseil. Und da macht man so ein Satelliten, legt man dann so rein wie so ein Katapult und dann lässt man unten los. Und dann fliegt es hoch und ist sehr gespannt. Keine Chance, dass das nicht klappt. Du brauchst nur genug hohe Katapulte. Selbst wenn du keine Luft im All hast, Gummiband müsste funktionieren. Spanns zerrt ja, die Spannkraft ist da.
Gummiband müsste eigentlich entschaffern.
Ich glaube, du hast da was.
Du hast jetzt zwei sehr grosse Stangen, wo du was dran spannst.
Und dann schießt es ins All.
Vor allem, wo wollen die eigentlich hin?
Also was ist das Ziel?
Die wollen auf andere Planeten.
Ist nicht die beste Idee, zu sagen, was ist das beste Raumschiff der Welt?
Das ist wie ein Sprichwort. Das beste Raumschiff der Welt ist das ... Naja, jetzt schau mal an. Was, rückblickend historisch, was waren die besten Raumschiffe der Welt? Was war am besten, durchs Universum zu reisen? Planeten. Planet ist das erfolgreichste Raumschiff. Im Grunde ist die Erde ein Raumschiff. Das wir kennen. Wir sind die Besatzung und wir fliegen alle durchs Raum und alle. Und du bist mein Lieblings Co-Pilot. Och, dankeschön. Und jetzt brauchen wir entweder, wir sagen, okay, die Erde, wir machen jetzt ernst, die Erde ist unser Raumschiff, wir bauen Turbinen an die Erde dran und schieben uns einfach dahin, wo wir sein wollen und springen dann einfach rüber mit einer kleinen Planke. Wir fliegen direkt zum Mond. Das haben wir gerade gelernt. Kugeln, wenn Kugeln ... Ja, genau! Können nicht an Kugeln anlegen.
Stimmt, ah shit, da brauchen wir halt noch so eine Planke.
Wir brauchen noch so eine Plank, mit der wir dann einfach von der Erde
auf den Mond hüpfen können, oder wir fliegen mal zum Saturn,
da gibt's so einen Plan,, mit der wir dann einfach von der Erde auf den Mond hüpfen können.
Oder wir fliegen mal zum Saturn, da gibt es so einen Plan, in jedem Treppenhaus hängt dann der Plan auf, Montag Saturn, Dienstag Neptun, je nachdem was ich brauche, kann ich dann immer halt rüberhüpfen über die Plank. Und dann sind wir alle unterwegs, weil dann können wir das alles bündeln und das war eigentlich viel besser. Oder, ich sehe schon in deinen Augen, wir machen künstlichen Planeten.
Wir bauen einen künstlichen Stern, den lassen wir erschaffen, den lassen wir bauen und wir werden einen Luftschacht einbauen.
Nur für den Fall.
Ich weiß, da kommen Fragen für den Fall.
Für den Fall, dass wir uns politisch ein bisschen verrennen mit diesem künstlichen Planeten. Diesem ja doch sehr ambitionierten Projekt. Dass wir dann zumindest die Chance haben, aufgehalten werden zu können. Das ist doch keine schlechte Idee. Du hast schon recht mit dem erfolgreichsten Raumschiff, aber wir wissen halt auch nicht von erfolgreichen Rennraumschiffen. Vielleicht gibt es im Universum da draußen erfolgreiche Raumschiffe als unseren Planeten, den blauen Planeten Erde. Vielleicht müssen wir auch irgendwie durch die fünfte Dimension reisen oder halt so ein Kram halten. Ich möchte jedenfalls Scheine machen und MS Erde, fliege ich schon seit 25 Jahren mittlerweile. Gibt es einen Menschen, der alle Scheine hat? Bestimmt. Der alle hat? Weil es ist Schein definiert als etwas, das jeder machen kann. Das ist natürlich nicht so. Beigt jemanden, etwas zu tun. Ja, aber auch, was jeder machen kann. Ich meine, so ein Chirurg hat keinen Schein, sondern das ist was anderes. Und so ein Amateurding. Fischereibetrieb? Jetzt schon möchte ich callen. Ich werde irgendwann mal einen Pilotenschein machen. Das möchte ich unbedingt. Ja. Ich warte noch ein bisschen drauf. Segelsflug? Damit kann man anfangen. Segelboot, Segelflug, Pilot.
Ich musste mich ja in meinem Schülerpraktikum intensiv mit Segelflug auseinandersetzen. Und da habe ich viel gelernt. Aber du warst in der Museumsabteilung für Segelflug, ne? Genau, ich war im Praktikum im Deutschen Museum gemacht. Nicht wie andere jetzt denken, dass du actually geflogen bist. Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Es war meine Aufgabe, Segelflug so attraktiv wie möglich für junge Menschen darzustellen.
Wie viele haben wegen dir mit dem Segelflugsport angefangen?
Niemand. Nicht mal ich. Wenn nicht mal ich, der so schmackhaft wie es geht, dieses Thema für Jugendliche, weil mein Chef meinte, die Leute spielen zu viele Videospiele, die lungern zu viel auf der Strasse rum, die Jugend muss in die Luft, die müssen fliegen, sonst wird aus denen nichts, sammel du doch was. Junge Menschen gehören nicht vor den Computer, sie gehören in mehreren tausend kmh in die Luft. In Fieberglas. Sie müssen in kleinen Plastikgeräten durch die Luft schießen. Da gehören die hin. Und ich als Praktikant hinterfrag das nicht und sag mir, ja, okay. Ich meine, besser sind Sie Segelflieger, als dass Sie Drogen nehmen oder Breakdance oder Breakfast machen. Weiß ich das nicht. Ehrliche These, es sind in Deutschland mehr Leute im Segelflugzeug gestorben als an Ecstasy. Weiß ich nicht, aber gut, niemand hindert dich daran, Thesen aufzustellen. Ja, ist eine These, okay. Und da musste ich das zusammentragen und ich musste das natürlich so, man muss dann den Test machen und man kann schon nach sechs Monaten in seinem eigenen Segelflieger stehen, schweben. Da bist du wirklich ganz alleine. Da bist du ganz alleine und du wirst dann entweder von so einem grossen Katapult
geschossen. Ich kenne die, ich war da früher.
Und dann fliegst du halt hin und dann musst
du halt gucken, wie du weiterkommst.
Wie du wieder runterkommst.
Ja, runterkommen sie alle.
Klassischer Pilotentruf, den musst du auch
lernen bei deinem Pilotentruf.
Runter kommen sie alle.
Ich mache einen Schein, ich hab da Bock drauf. Scheine machen das Leben besser. Irgendwann gibt's auch so Ecofuel und so was, und dann ist das Fliegen auch nicht mehr so eine Peitsche gegen die Planeten Erde. Ich überleg, welchen Schein könnte ich machen. Ja, ich hätte Schein wäre, was für dich? Ja, ich hätte gerne so vielleicht so was mit Natur, vielleicht so Förster. Ein Jagdschein. Ja, ne, Jagd nicht, aber Försterschein. Ja, Jagdschein ist ja auch was, um die Natur zu preserven. Ja, stimmt schon. Vielleicht so einen Tannenzapfenschein, so dass ich selber Tannenzapfen sammeln und einpflanzen kann. Falkenereischein? Spannend. Das wäre was für dich. Natürlich. Cool, cool, cool. Cool, cool, cool. Falken sind schon interessant. Es gibt Falken mit einer Kamera drauf. Kann man sehen, wie die fliegen. Ist auch nicht so spannend. Ich finde es mega. Ja, man denkt, es ist mega. Man guckt sich dann so ein YouTube-Video an und noch 20 Sekunden. Es ist für 20 Minuten mega cool und dann nicht mehr so cool. Es ist nicht mehr so cool. Falknerei könnte ich mir schon vorstellen. Da hat man natürlich als Rollenspieler sehr viel Erfahrung damit, weil jeder zweite Spieler einen Charakter mit einem Falken spielen will. Und man als Spielleiter einfach schon viel Erfahrung damit hat, mit ... ja, ich schick meinen Falken, um einen Hasen zu jagen. Okay, du hast einen Hasen.
Können wir das Abenteuer fortsetzen, bitte, mit dem Dimensionsriss und dem Dämonenlord, der versucht, die Weltherrschaft an sich zu reißen?
Ich versuche mit meinem Falken, dass der über den Dämonen Dimensionsriss fliegt und dann so ein Tannenzapfen in den Riss wirft.
Okay, der Falk ist schirmt. Der Falk ist tot,, der Fall ist in einer anderen Dimension. So, du bist dran. Immer dasselbe. Ich habe jetzt auch ein paar Mal DSA gespielt, mit einem Freundeskreis, haben wir endlich mal angefangen, Rollenspiel zu spielen, DSA zu spielen, macht sehr viel Spaß. Ah, DSA 5 nehme ich mal an. Ja, meiner Erfahrung nach, wir haben immer mit anderen Charakteren gespielt, um ein bisschen zu experimentieren, zu gucken. Was spielst du, Welche Charakter spielst du? Jetzt letztes Mal war ich zum Zauberer. Wow. Super schwierig zu spielen. Ich habe mir auch ganz komische Zauberer draufgeskillt und dann konnte ich den einmal im Abenteuer machen. Und danach hatte ich keine, wie heißt das nochmal, Mana? ASP, ASP. ASP mehr. Das ist ganz typisch. Furchtbar nichts mehr und war langweilig.
Da habe ich auch noch so einen super alten,
arroganten Charakter gespielt.
Wenn man das ernst nimmt, dann macht er auch viel alleine und langweiligen Kram alleine.
Ich habe so einen Sachuman, so einen alten, weissen Zauberer,
der so keine Lust mehr hat auf die ...
Aber es macht auch keinen Sinn, dass er bei dem Abenteuer dabei macht.
Das sind immer so typische DSA-Probleme. Und was mir aufgefallen ist bei diesen drei Abenteuern, die wir gespielt haben, es ist immer der gleiche Modus. Man trifft sich in der Taverne, stellt sich nicht richtig vor, weiss trotzdem alles über den anderen, weil man sich davor schon sehr viel mit den anderen Charakteren auseinandergesetzt hat und Fragen beantwortet hat, wie ja, macht es hier Sinn, dass ich einen Falken habe? Ja, okay, wohl der hat einen Falken. Man weiss schon alles übereinander, man macht dann so ein Powerplay und weiss im Prinzip nichts übereinander, weil man sich das nie vorstellt, kommt dann durch irgendein Ereignis, was einen nicht zusammenschweissen sollte, schweißt einen das trotzdem irgendwie zusammen, dass man beschließt ja jetzt gemeinsam auf dieses Abenteuer, um uns das Geld am Ende zu teilen. Ja. Okay, dann gibt es immer einen mysteriösen Hinweis, dann weiß man kurz immer nicht, was man tun soll, geht dem nach, folgt der ersten Spur, ist sich sicher, man hat fünfzehn verschiedene Hinweise im Dorf liegen lassen, geht dann schon mal irgendwo hin und dann trifft man da oft auf einen ersten Kampf. Dann gibt es immer, es gibt nämlich den Anfang der Taverne, in der Mitte gibt es immer den einen leichten Kampf, den man übersteht und am Ende gibt es immer den Finalkampf, der schwierig wird und meistens nur mit einem Toten oder zwei sehr schwer Verletzten überstanden werden kann. Und dann hat man gar keine Lust mehr, weil es dann viel zu spät schon oft ist für das Abenteuer. Und dann kommt dieses ganze Aftermath, es ist einem allen egal, niemand hat mehr zu, die Leute packen schon den Rucksack und wollen nach Hause. So meiner Erfahrung nach ist es immer gleich. Aber es macht Spaß, es ist super cool. Man macht es dann wieder. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Man macht es dann wieder. Aber man merkt schon, dass es nicht so geil ist, wenn man die Charaktere noch nicht so richtig fühlt und so. Er ist ja auch ein schwieriger Charakter für einen Einsteiger, würde ich sagen. Was würdest du empfehlen für mich als Einsteiger? Puh, schwierig. Kommt darauf an, es ist oft gar nicht so schlecht. DSA ist aber auch schwierig als Einsteiger. Es ist schwierig, aber es ist oft gar nicht so schlecht, sich einfach Vorbilder zu nehmen, Dinge, die es schon gibt. Aber vielleicht, gerade Magie ist natürlich super schwierig. Ja, habe ich auch. Ich hatte auch mal so einen George Costanza-artigen. Gut, das sind natürlich Vorbilder, die schwierig sind. Krieger. Und das war. So, ich will so einen Moe Sislak von den Simpsons spielen. Okay. Wobei man George Costanza, a.k.a. Larry David, auch sehr gut spielen kann. Ja, ja. Hilft einem halt im Kampf nicht. Ja, ist schwierig. Aber das ist alles noch was Besonderes, weil da gibt es echt einige Professionen, die wirklich schwierig sind, wo man die Welt gut kennen muss. Aber ja, finde ich, jeder macht das auch nach seinem eigenen Tempo und ist ja auch in Ordnung. Das machen wir auch mal. Wir machen mal irgendwann ein Podcast-Hofen-Rollenspiel. Ja, können wir auf jeden Fall machen. Ist das dann nur wir zwei oder was? Einer ist Spielleiter, der andere ist Spieler. Nee, das suchen wir uns dann mal für ein paar Folgen. Links oder rechts? Rechts. Okay, guck's nach.
Okay, da kommt jetzt erstmal zwei Tage lang nichts mehr. Okay. Kann ich schlafen? Kann ich, kann ich, und dann immer die Frage, kann ich mir so eine krasse Superwaffe bauen aus dem Holz, das hier rumliegt? Nein. Du siehst rechts am Horizont siehst du, sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Bauernhof, ist aber ein bisschen grösser als ein Bauernhof. Ja, ich mache weiter meine Waffe. Du siehst einige Pferde, dir fällt aber auf, dass die Pferde ungewöhnlich aktiv sind. Also die laufen hin und her, manche stellen sich so auf den Hinterbeinen auf, wieren und es ist erstmal ein ungewöhnlicher Handling. Sehe ich sonst noch was? Sehe ich irgendwo was zum Looten? Nee, erstmal nicht, aber du schaust noch mal weiter auf die Pferde
und dir fällt auf, dass tatsächlich eines der Pferde anfängt,
ein anderes Pferd so in den Nacken zu beissen.
Äh, okay.
Diese Waffe, kann ich mir die bauen, die mit dem so eine Katapultartige Waffe,
weißt du, wo man irgendwie so ...
Nein, du bist alleine in der Wildnis unterwegs.
So zwei ... na, aber so zwei grosse Äste
und ich hab ja noch dieses Seil von diesem Boss bekommen gestern.
Wie soll die Waffe aussehen?
Willst du einen Bogen bauen?
Ja, so einen Katab... ja,
Bogenbau. Waffe mal Holzbearbeitung.
Nicht bestanden.
Also, du findest keinen richtigen Ast, aber während
du nach dem Ast suchst,
hörst du,
wie dieses Viren immer
lauter wird. Und es ist
wirklich, du kennst dich mit Pferden nicht so gut aus,
Das ist eine immer so, dann greifen wir uns an. Aber ich find's 20 cool, wir machen das mit einer kleinen Gruppe. Du bist Spielmeister und wir machen eine kleine Podcast-Uvo-Gruppe. Thais spielt eine Rolle, ob sie will oder nicht. Ob sie Podcast ist mittlerweile hart. Thais ist ein Braugummi-Count an ihrem Handy einfach. Hat keinen Bock mehr, Thais spielt jetzt mit. So wie, es ist Familienabend, es ist Spielabend. Du machst jetzt mit. Sie macht mit und dann gucken wir mal, Julia. Ja, finde ich gut, können wir gerne machen. Aber ist es dann auch so Fantasy-mäßig oder dann? Komplett Fantasy. Richtig Hardcore-Fantasy. Hardcore, no Bullshit, maximal unzugänglich Fantasy. Okay. Ja? Ist das ein Pitch? Leute da draußen, habt ihr Bock? Habt ihr Bock? Ich finde es gut. Ja, machen wir, auf jeden Fall. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch aber natürlich noch eine fantastische Woche, haut rein und ganz kurzer Disclaimer, wir beenden an der Stelle die Einsendephase für das Giftfestival, Einsendeschluss ist jetzt, je nachdem wann ihr es hört, aber genau jetzt und es werden keine weiteren Gifts mehr angenommen und freut euch darauf, wir werden bald die grosse Gif-Festival-Auslosung und Presse planen. Genau, wir werden bald die Nominierten bekannt geben. Das alles findet, wie ihr schon vielleicht euch denken könnt, nicht in diesem Podcast statt. Richtig, keine so visuelles Medium mehr. Wir haben festgestellt, dass es vielleicht nicht das beste Medium ist, um Gif-Festival auszurufen, wie dem auch sei, having said that, was wir auch im Deutschen brauchen übrigens, das vorangestellt, werden wir das alles bei Instagram machen und hinkriegen.
Also folgt uns dafür auf Instagram, das Podcast UFO, falls ihr euch für GIFs interessiert, ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche.
Macht's gut, wir heben ab!